Как побороть волнение перед публичным
выступлением Я сегодня хочу дать вам
самый действенный способ который
проверен на практике наверняка каждый из
вас сталкивается с такой ситуацией когда
вам нужно выступить перед аудиторией А
вас захватывает волнение вы не можете
справиться с со своим волнением вас
трясёт и многие из вас кстати Именно
из-за этого страха отказываются от
публичного выступлений вы знаете когда
вы отказываетесь от публичных
выступлений вы лишаете себя огромного
пласта возможно
поэтому не стоит
пренебрегать умением выступать на
публике это надо оттачивать но в то же
время я вас прекрасно понимаю потому что
в молодости когда я только начинал
выступать перед публикой У меня тоже был
очень сильный мандраж мне тряслись руки
у меня дрожал голос у меня в голове все
мысли разлетались я их не мог собрать в
одну кучку И сегодня я хочу с вами
поделиться железобетонным способом
который я для себя открыл и я нигде не
видел этого в Интернете Ставьте лайк и
слушайте дальше как вообще появился Этот
способ Однажды Меня попросили выступить
перед депутатами и там был президент
страны это было девяностые годы я тогда
не был ну не
осознавал всей этой ситуации того что
может со мной произойти Я легкомысленно
согласился и когда я уже сидел в зале и
я понимал что следующая очередь
выступать мне меня меня хватил вот этот
мандраж меня начало так трясти меня
начало так колбасить У меня поднялось
давление у меня все мои заготовленные
мысли всё в голове всё разлетелось я не
мог сосредоточиться ни на ни на одной
мысли и я понимал что следующий
выступать мне и я понимал что это конец
Это конец это позор и только счастливая
Случайность мне помогла открыть этот
способ А эта счастливая Случайность
заключалась в том
что после выступления оратора
который выступал передо мной туда
вклиниться другой выступающий и где-то
минут на 20-30 это дало мне определённую
передышку и благодаря этому в какой-то
момент я успокоился и я обрёл такую
железобетонную уверенность и спокойствие
все мои мысли пришли в порядок и я
спокойно вышел на трибуну и выступил я
был в шоке Я не понимал что произошло по
я начал анализировать а произошло
оказывается Вот что дело в том что все
наши вот эти мандраж страхи волнения и
потеря мысли - это на самом деле работа
нашей гормональной системы когда мы
Волнуемся и боимся то идёт бешеный
выброс адреналина Адреналин это
Адреналин наш колбасит так вот когда Нас
колбасит Адреналин мы не можем ни на чём
сосредоточиться плохая новость то что
Адреналин это всё вызывает быт эти
реакции но хорошая новость в том что
адреналин не может держаться долго на
высоком уровне гормон Адреналин
выбрасывается вас колбасит но на пике он
находиться долго не может достаточно
15-20 минут и уровень адреналина
начинает падать И как только он приходит
в норму вы не можете волноваться Как бы
вы не хотели обязательно Расскажите свою
историю в комментариях о том как вы
справлялись со своим волнением И вообще
как проходило ваше первое выступление на
публике и отсюда Я вывел лайфхак и даже
расскажу как я его в жизни опробовал
Однажды Я выступал во дворце Республики
Это был большой форум организованный
альфабанком по-моему должен был
выступать Я и после меня должен был
выступать Один квнщик он знаменитый
квнщик ээ очень много играл и он пришёл
ко мне в гримёр его трясёт колотит
колбасит и он говорит Ага Помогите ну
ага - это по казахское обращение к
старшему Помогите не могу с собой
совладать что со мной происходит не могу
волнение страшное волнение я узнал себя
в молодости а он молодой и ему говорю ты
знаешь говорю тебе конец говорю вот
смотри сколько ты репутацию собирал свою
играл в КВН стал известным знаменитым и
так далее И ты сейчас всё сольёт в
канализацию ты сейчас говорю на сцену
выйдешь двух слов связать не можешь ты в
таком состоянии что у тебя полный конец
это твоей репутации твоей карьеры конец
ты сейчас выйдешь просто будешь мычать
только на сцене представляешь у тебя
мысли не соберутся поэтому говорю это
всё это конец это позор сейчас ты орёшь
это будет
просто неописуемо
и говорю Ну ты меня дождись я приду
сейчас всё будет нормально Я выступил
возвращаюсь он сидит как и ожидал
как в танке Я говорю что случилось он
говорит Не знаю вот как-то я вот воды
наверное попил или что как-то вот
успокоился и тогда я ему рассказал суть
лайфхака Я говорю Смотри что я сделал Я
искусственно нагнал на те жути всех
страхов чтобы выдавить из твоей
гормональной системы весь Адреналин
который он есть чтобы весь Адреналин
выбросился в кровь чтобы ты почувствовал
всю катастрофу и ужас я нарисовал тебе
такие жути которые твоё воображение даже
не подсказывало благодаря этому весь
Адреналин выбросился прошло 20-30 минут
и всё у тебя адреналина нет И ты
успокоился теперь говорю ты пойдёшь на
сцену что бы не произошло ты будешь как
в танке и действительно он когда пошёл и
выступил он весь зал держал он он
буквально игрался с залом он так
хахлыновой
это было неописуемо Это было просто
такой такое удовольствие и кайф Я у него
тогда спросил говорю интересно ты же
вроде в КВНе выступал известный человек
А как так получилось что ты на сцене не
мог выступить сегодня Ну боялся
выступить он говорит Дело в том что
выступление на КВНе - это совсем другое
там заранее прописаны сценарии заранее
прописаны шутки мы знаем что говорить
когда говорить плюс мы это делаем в
команде плюс аудитория готова смеяться
от любого нашего жеста она
подготовленная и мы там чувствуем себя
уверенно А тут говорит Меня пригласили
на Деловой форум выступить перед
огромным количеством бизнесменов а
бизнесмены - это люди серьёзные и тема
по которой Я выступал сегодня она тоже
серьёзная Поэтому меня сегодня так
колбасино Но а я в этой истории убедился
ещё раз в том что вот этот метод
работает с железо бетона Поэтому в
следующий раз когда вы будете выступать
где-либо перед серьёзным мероприятием
или перед серьёзными людьми и вас будет
колбасить и шторми Возьмите Нарисуйте
себе воображение конца света просто
Представьте что вам конец что вашей
репутации конец что вы просто оботе и
весь зал будет над вами ржать И вообще
вы покроется с позором на всю жизнь и
таким образом попытайтесь за полчаса до
вашего выступления выжать весь Адреналин
из своей гормональной системы и когда
произойдёт выплеск адреналина на пике
вас будет трясти и колбасить но через
152025 минут он придёт в норму и ничто
не сможет Вас проши бить в вашей голове
будет полная ясность вы будете
расслаблены и вы будете готовы ко всему
это железный железобетонный способ с
которым я сегодня хотел бы с вами
поделиться